The collapse of Venezuela’s economy is both
horrifying and pr edictable,
and the world needs to understand why.
Venezuela has the world’s largest proven
oil reserves,
and it was once Latin America’s richest country.
Caracas the swinging city of Venezuela!
Good climate. Fine Buildings.
Wide highways with plenty on them.
All in all, a pretty nice place to be for many reasons.
Today, most grocery store shelves are empty,
and Venezuelans are so hungry
that they’re killing zoo animals for sustenance.
Toilet paper, diapers, and toothpaste are
luxury goods.
Venezuelan hospitals have disintegrated, children
are dying because they can’t get antibiotics,
and the infant mortality rate is higher than
Syria's.
The capital city of Caracas is the murder
capital of the world.
And just 12 percent of citizens feel safe walking alone at night,
which is the lowest figure reported in the world.
The government blames slumping oil prices
for the desperate situation.
The real cause is the socialist economy.
The government sets the price of staples such as rice, pasta, and flour,
resulting in chronic shortages.
Former President Hugo Chavez nationalized
industries, confiscated property,
and kicked out foreign companies.
The government is trying to print its way
out of the crisis,
resulting in a 700 percent annual inflation rate.
After a sham election, President Nicolas Maduro,
the handpicked successor of Chavez,
is rounding up his opponents and putting them in jail.
Despite this, Maduro and his predecessor still have their defenders,
ranging from Sean Penn to Michael Moore to Naomi Klein,
who once
signed a petition saying:
“We would vote for Hugo Chavez”
and praised the autocrat in 2007
for creating “a zone of relative economic calm and predictability.”
In 2013, journalist David Sirota praised Hugo
Chavez’s “economic miracle,”
writing that the socialist leader had a “record that a legacy-obsessed American president
could only dream of achieving."
But the real lesson of Venezuela’s tragic collapse
is that real socialism always leads to economic breakdown and political repression.
Those of us in wealthier, freer countries
need to keep Venezuela in mind
as we confront calls for more regulation and government control
of all aspects of our own lives.